let's just get right into things today
because there is so much to cover
uh one of the things i mentioned in my
monday segment about the current
israeli-palestinian flare-up
is that not only does hamas benefit from
what's going on
because they justify their existence by
being on the receiving end of
israeli rockets but benjamin netanyahu
justifies
his position as prime minister as mr
security
when there are at this point i believe
it's 3500 hamas rockets
that have been shot in the direction of
israel and
i even mentioned benjamin netanyahu
likely realizes that unless something
changes his days as prime minister are
numbered unable to form a government
recently
he was recently interviewed on cbs face
the nation by john dickerson
and dickerson to his credit went right
at this idea and said essentially
are you killing people to try to stay in
power that's the crux
of it let's look at the exchange let me
get before you neither arab skilling is
wrong
or jews killing arabs or arabs killing
jews let me ask i want you to respond to
one other thing before we go which is
your domestic
challenges you are under investigation
for bribery fraud breach of trust
you've also had some uh difficulty four
failed attempts to put together a
government in the last 23 months
this leads to the criticism that your
current actions
are basically an effort to stay in power
and what's your response to that
that's preposterous you know i when i
was a young soldier 18 years old
i held a fellow soldier who died in my
arms
a few years later my brother my older
brother died while
uh leading a rescue mission in entebbe
uganda to release israeli hostages
i've seen comrades fall i've seen my
brother fall
and i think anybody who knows me knows
that i've never ever
subordinated security concerns the life
of our soldiers the life of our citizens
for political interests that's just
hogwash i'll do what i have to do
to protect the lives of israeli citizens
and to restore peace i've made peace
with four arab countries
i'm glad that we have a restoration of
some
considerable calm within israel that's
my goal to restore
peace and quiet and to assure
tranquility
and reconciliation for all but this is a
persistent criticism mr prime minister
why do you think it persists
it persists because i've been re-elected
five times it persists because
i beat every other candidate in public
polls and in direct election
simulations apparently the people of
israel the majority don't agree
with this false criticism and this
cynicism they know
that i'm standing there for israel and
i'm doing everything i can
for the safety and prosperity of the
israeli people by the way
all of israel citizens jews and arabs
alike all right mr prime minister we're
out of time
this is not idle speculation the
associated press
reports that quote just over a week ago
the longtime israeli leader's political
career
seemed all but over he had failed to
form a coalition government
following an indecisive parliamentary
election and his political rivals were
on the cusp of pushing him out of office
now as israel and gaza's hamas rulers
wage their fourth war in just over a
decade
netanyahu's fortunes have changed
dramatically
his rivals prospects have crumbled
netanyahu is back in his comfortable
role as mr security
and the country could soon be headed for
yet another election campaign
that would guarantee him at least
several more
months in office rightly this is making
many
people ask was this another one of these
disgusting cynical moves that we've come
to expect from benjamin netanyahu we saw
this before
during the lead-up to an election in
israel and
exactly as i suggested i suspected on
monday
more people are now asking this exact
same question and
there's every indication that this is
exactly what is going on will it work
i wish i could say no but sadly it might
and of course
the longer netanyahu remains in power as
well as the longer hamas remains in
power
the prospects of a real peace deal are
essentially zero
as i outlined earlier this week one of
our sponsors today is
covid rescue fund covid rescue fund
is helping small business owners who
have lost
their businesses during covid there are
over 100
000 small businesses that have had to
close their doors
since the pandemic began there are many
organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open to
stay afloat
but covet rescue fund is one of the few
organizations working to help businesses
reopen
who have had to close covet rescue fund
crowdsources funds
to provide grants up to one hundred
thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund
in their mission by donating at
covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video